i'm now joined by anakin fitfeld the
norwegian foreign minister foreign
minister ukraine has been launching
quite a successful counter-offensive in
recent days how much is norway prepared
to deliver to ukraine so that this
momentum can actually be seized
prime minister sturrid visited the kiev
this summer
and promised
funding to ukraine for like 1 billion
euro which i think will be important
this money goes to weapons of course
but also to humanitarian assistance and
also money so they can
buy more gas
so it's important for us to unite with
ukraine
and no way we haven't delivered weapons
to to counter countries in conflict for
more than 60 years but we changed the
practice when this war started
like countries like sweden and finland
also did so
there's a enormous solidarity
with the ukrainian people
in norway we do also have a border to
russia so we know what this neighbor is
about even though they have a different
policy up in the high north
than they have towards ukraine
so changing this position of actually
delivering weapons to a crisis area that
is of course something that you have in
common with a country like germany we've
also changed our position here in this
country
what should germany be doing which
weapons should it deliver to ukraine
well it's a purely german decision
so
that's my message
but as an overall view
i think it has been very important that
western countries have been sending
weapons to ukraine so they can be able
to protect themselves
without those weapons there would be
another game in another situation in
ukraine right now norway also supports
ukraine in terms of delivering
humanitarian aid now you've come to
berlin to discuss the topic of gender
issues in foreign policy
so which role do gender issues play in
this conflict with russia we get several
reports about
how women are affected on the ground we
can see rapes used as a weapon in this
war and also other wars all around the
world so we need to focus very clearly
on the consequences for both men and
women in this conflict
and more broadly perhaps gender issues
in foreign policy is something that
norway has long advocated for but it is
a topic that not many countries so far
have been taking on board that is
beginning to change
and why are the scandinavian countries
such an exception and what can other
countries learn from your country
we have this experience that if we are
bringing women
to the table
in a conflict situation
the peace deal tend to last longer
basically because their perspectives are
being brought in
we see that in several conflicts in the
world
we have hosted
a dialogue between
the different groups in colombia for
like 10 years to get with cuba
and there has been
very many women
led delegations women have been included
around the table
as victims but also as mediators so
that's absolutely crucial in order to
let peace still last
norway supports
multilateralism as an approach to
essentially look at solutions for
worldwide conflicts now multilateralism
is being tested in the arctic of course
where melting ice is now bringing more
natural resources to the surface and
countries like the us and china and
russia are using this field to pursue
their own strategic interests how
uncomfortable is this for norway
well i think it's a general description
of the situation
that there is more like status quo in
the arctic
we are trying to do our atmos to keep
low tension
in the high north but we can really see
very visible the climate changes
up there
and we need to cooperate very strongly
with the other arctic nations
norway has of course been a nato member
from the very start of the alliance now
finland and sweden also in scandinavia
are about to join the alliance what
hopes do you have for their membership
it means a lot to our security because
we have been working stronger and
stronger together with finland and
sweden over the last
years
after 1989 but still there has been have
been limitations due to the fact that
they have been
neutral and we have been a member of
nato but now it's very much easier
to build a common defense strategy that
will make norway safer
the nato alliance has given itself this
goal of spending two percent of the
national budget
on defence
now what is the discussion in norway
right now do people feel like more is
necessary
yeah we do have a program now for
strengthening
our military presence up in the high
north we have a very special security
policy
because we
base our
security policy on the churns
together with allies so we host a huge
military exercise
earlier this spring with thousands of
soldiers from
close allies around europe and also
canada and
united states came to the norwegian
waters and took took
that took place in
in nowhere this spring but on the other
hand we also trying to do our atmos to
keep low tension
and by doing that
we are balancing norwegian interest up
in the high north and which lessons can
be drawn from russia's war on ukraine
for other crises around the world
we've been in the security council for
almost two years now
and we have been able even in this
situation to find common solutions
by working very closely
with other countries in the security
council and this is very important that
we don't get a spill over effect to
other conflicts i mean some conflicts
will be more difficult to solve
but others
may be a window of opportunity because
this conflict this war has global
consequences
uh we can see food increase in food
prices increase in energy prices
however we need to maintain the
architecture as good as we can but it's
difficult to work with russia now of
course
when you look at other crises around the
world which are the crises that you have
your eye on most
we are working strongly
on colombia and also venezuela
i am going to share a meeting in a donor
group for palestine
when i'm going to new york next week
and a new situation in the middle east
where we need to encourage
more dialogue between
all the countries in that region
will also be a priority
for norway so we have been taking part
in many talks
during the last
30 years however we never put pressure
on the parties that's not the norwegian
model
but we will be happy if
countries or parts in a conflict
would invite norway as a mediator in
several of these conflicts
here in europe many people for decades
have relied on the fact that the us
would ultimately protect europe and that
european countries don't need to be too
active themselves but we've seen the
united states be more and more focused
on the indo-pacific so what should a
country like germany which is of course
one of europe's strongest countries
do in terms of protecting europe
well that's actually my point when i'm
giving speeches about the new security
there will be less attention from united
states because they have their eyes on
what's happening in in asia and that
part of the world and we need to take
major core
care of our own territories and germany
certainly are stepping up
and we've had a very very strong
cooperation with germany during the last
years and this will be strengthened
strengthened i think in the years to
come
would your country consider joining the
european union there are different
opinions on that in
in no way we had one referendum in 72
where people voted no and another one in
94 where also the majority of people
voted no
but there is
ongoing debate in a way in society
whether we should join or not anakin
whitfeld norwegian foreign minister
thank you very much
you